here at Einstein bagels picking up
decaffeinated bagels that everybody is
talking about I call it double buzz they
can have a coffee and a bagel with your
caffeine
yes yes it's about right oh yeah I drink
coffee every day for sure you ever drink
coffee today though no doesn't seem like
it already had two cups this morning so
I'm gonna be like yeah I'm like
imagining like those like hipsters who
like drink coffee and like it this bagel
at the same time I'm actually excited
cuz I love bagel I love bagels I love
coffee you are slow right now
you look very sleepy you sound variously
be you Jaffee please give me caffeine it
looks good yeah it does
they smell chocolaty smell oh they do
smell chocolate yeah so we're gonna try
it plain and unco stood and then toasted
with cream cheese I feel like the coffee
subtle when I breathe out I get a little
bit of that bitterness of my sinuses I'm
bad at tasting things like I don't have
really good sense of what our job is
you're Busbee yeah
the aftertaste does taste like express
over something yeah
definitely tastes fresh oh it's very
good the solid bagel good but a little
too bitter as well yeah I didn't the
cream cheese in know for sure I think
this is gonna taste good because you say
it's like you can taste like the
bitterness sort of of the expresso say
then the cream cheese which should give
a little it's sweet flavor to it would
be nice
mmm I like with the cream cheese ooh mmm
delicious you go wrong with cream cheese
really oh yeah that's really good I
actually would really like this with a
cup of coffee I feel like that would be
like the perfect complement to it I feel
like I'd feel more awake but I know
that's placebo are actually doing with
this I do it I really do love it yeah
it's a good bagel especially for la la
mm-hmm
usually LA bagels are garbage so it is
pretty good but not enough caffeine for
my taste I don't think it's gonna affect
me like that much I feel like this is
more of like a thing that I will eat
with my coffee for me it's not useful to
have a third of a cup of coffee and a
bagel so yeah I probably wanted to be
stronger so it's been about an hour's to
add the coffee bagel and I feel like
pretty awake that like to have a cup of
coffee so what it's been about three
hours since we have the expresso buzz
bagel or whatever hell it's called and
you know I have some energy still you
know I feel like it's been sustaining me
throughout the whole day I never really
felt anything
um other than full would eat it again
but me more coffee
to be honest they taste pretty good to
me but I don't feel energized from
eating them I feel like I do still need
to get my coffee intake I haven't had
any coffee today the other day and
basically the bagel and I'm not tired
usually at this time I need a cup of
coffee to wake up and actually work but
right now I'm not tired at all one thing
I have noticed though is that it's been
making me poop a little bit more which I
know coffee does to me sometimes so yeah
I've been proving more to because of it
good job bagel are there any other
liquids you can see making being turned
into a bagel I'll cool it for sure a
Coolidge bagel let's get on it